to the pressure campaign on speaker
nancy pelosi it's a chinese spy scandal
surrounding democrat congressman eric
swalwell
is not going away republicans of course
want him
off the house intel committee and they
are narrowing their focus on the speaker
to do just that
to ohio republican congressman brad
wenstrup he is one of those who wants
him
off he sits on the intel committee with
congressman suawell congressman wenstrup
good to see you
i must say the biggest curiosity for me
is how somebody like swalwell got on the
intel committee to begin with he was a
rookie congressman
he had zero experience in intel uh
not to say not just that but overseas
experience was limited
you for example you're not only a
physician you're also a
army uh i believe you're an army colonel
in reserve you were an iraq war veteran
so how did he get on how did a rookie
like swalwell get on such an important
committee to begin with
yeah well we've obviously got more
questions than we have answers and i
think that's the same for the american
people
and at the same time a lot of the
american people have no idea of what's
taking place with mr suava because
mainstream media doesn't seem
to want to talk about it but we've
always had concerns about this type of
espionage
that clearly took place the chinese
develop a farm team and
here's young eric swalwell working in
local government and and on the rise
and builds a relationship with this
woman who's a chinese spy
of course we want to know what pelosi
knew and when and want to know why she
would choose to put him on this
committee when she's got hundreds of
people to choose from
a lot of people want to get on this
committee it seems to me
that he should be disregarded from the
beginning because of this past
if she knew about it same same with adam
schiff knowing about it
but beyond that i also have some
concerns with the fbi if the fbi went to
eric swalwell and told him about this
and
knew of this woman why was she never
arrested
and why did the fbi basically just sweep
this under the carpet rather than
using it as an example to warn other
members and other
americans that this is the type of thing
that they do and how they try to operate
even down to the local government excuse
me let me let me just stop you there and
just ask is
it conceivable that the fbi was
investigating and you didn't know about
it
oh sure it is and and you know it
supposedly was the fbi who went to eric
swalwell
to inform him what was going on and then
she goes back to china
that concerns me but look you know this
has been a tough four years for all of
us
if you go back to who was in charge of
the fbi during that time
that this was all going on it was robert
mueller and james comey
i mean are they just in this habit of
trying to cover up
for democrats i don't know but they have
a lot of questions
i think that need to be answered as well
as well as speaker pelosi taking eric
swalwell
off the committee the optics of what he
was engaged in are horrible for us
if we're to be perceived as legitimate
and so it seems to me there's this
little california triangle
of nancy pelosi adam schiff and eric
swalwell
and we need to know why that is taking
there's there's another member of that
uh that committee and that that is
senator feinstein
she was she was penetrated her her
uh group was penetrated by a chinese spy
as well so they were
intent the chinese communist party was
intent on on getting everything
everybody they could involve with
california silicon valley area
uh that's clearly was was part of the
thing and fang fang the
the chinese communist spy that
befriended eric swalwell
uh she apparently was bundling money for
him
in a campaign even though she was a
chinese spy i'm just wondering if
are you curious as to whether any
chinese money that would have been
completely illegal
went into his campaign well as far as
that's been reported so far
is that none of the money came from
her directly but how she was able to
raise money from others
should also be looked at and to see what
the connections were there and maybe she
was just working everyday americans to
try and support this guy
that could be not everyone knew she was
a spy obviously well it's extraordinary
that he's still on the committee
i do i do want to very quickly switch
subjects and ask you the latest on covet
relief
uh any indication that uh that 600
direct payment to americans will be up
to two thousand dollars as the president
and many democrats actually want
well one of the things we proposed is to
go ahead and increase it but make some
reductions in foreign aid which could
easily be done
and you know the problem that we have is
we were working hard to provide aid to
the american people
it should never have been bundled with
these other entities
those are two separate issues and
americans have been held hostage by this
and nancy pelosi has put us off for
months and months and months
and now she ties it to these other
entities that should be completely
separate so
there's a lot of maneuvering going on
but we got to get the relief to the
american people that's one of my highest
priorities is to get that out the door
so that we don't find ourselves we're
still at risk of going into a depression
if we don't save save some people's
lives in business there's definitely the
possibility of a double dip recession
we'll have to
work as hard as we can to avoid that uh
doctor
colonel congressman wenstrup good to see
you thank you very much for being here
appreciate
it thank you dave my best to you and
your family thanks same to you